hi in this video we'll talk about
acute inflammation acute inflammation
is a short-term process occurring in
response to
tissue injury or pathogen invasion
usually this occurs within a minute
or hours acute inflammation is
characterized by
five cardinal signs pain redness
immobility swelling and heat
so let's talk about the purpose of acute
inflammation
it can occur to eliminate pathogens
or to prevent the spread of pathogen
within the body
acute inflammation can also remove
necrotic cells
after a tissue injury lastly it can also
initiate
repair process so overall inflammation
is not bad at all
inflammation at lower level can help the
body
and help the body to combat pathogen and
save the body from pathogen spreading
so let's talk about what are the basic
criteria to call it a acute inflammation
two criterias are crucial first of all
swelling and edema and second is
neutrophil invasion both of these
criterias are really important
acute inflammation can arise in response
to
several aspect first of all pathogen
infection where acute inflammation
ensures the elimination of the pathogen
also it can occur due to tissue necrosis
where acute inflammation can
help to eliminate the necrotic debris
now let's look at several cellular
aspects of inflammation
cell types like macrophages or dendritic
cells
are involved in acute inflammation
process it secretes
inflammatory cytokines such as
interleukin 1 6 or tumor necrosis
factor alpha which leads to this
molecular events of acute inflammation
acute inflammation is immediate but it
lacks kind of specificity it has very
limited specificity
so let's talk about what are the
mediators of acute inflammation
tone like receptor signaling arachidonic
acid metabolites
mast cells and complement cascades are
involved
in acute inflammation lastly the hagman
factor or factor
7 is also involved in this process
let's talk about what are the hallmarks
of
acute inflammation we have already
talked about this
and we know there are five cardinal
symptoms redness
warmth swelling pain and fever
so whenever we have redness and warmth
it increase
the blood flow in the underneath tissue
underneath
so after that vasodilation leads to
fluid leakage into the tissue space
which leads to
swelling of that particular area and
several mediators of vasodilations are
bradycainine prostaglandin and
histamines
prostaglandins also sensitize the
sensory nerve endings and that's the
basis of pain fever can also occur
due to inflammation several bacteria has
toxins like
lps which acts like a pyrogen and
that allows macrophages and other cell
types to secrete pre-inflammatory
cytokine
and in response to pro-inflammatory
cytokine our
brain increase the cycle oxygenase
activity
and that leads to temperature disbalance
and increase of the temperature
so body's temperature homeostasis is
altered under these circumstances
now let's quickly look at the cellular
and molecular changes during
acute inflammation first and foremost
thing that happens
is diabetes or neutrophil infiltration
now neutrophils move around the blood
vessels
but when there is an inflammation
cytokines can cause change into the
blood vessel walls
neutrophil also start expressing uh
adhesion molecules on their surfaces
such as e selecting
or s lex all of these adhesion molecules
lead to slow down of the neutrophil and
when the neutrophil is slowed down
it undergoes cytoskeletal rearrangement
and it can squeeze itself out into the
inflamed
area neutrophils once it reach into the
inflamed area it can
engulf pathogens it can phagocytosis
phagocytose pathogens and destroy these
pathogens with lysosomal enzymes
now apart from neutrophil other cellular
players which are involved in
acute inflammation are macrophages and
dendritic cells
these macrophages and dendritic cells
both are
a source for inflammatory cytokine
and both of them can phagocytose
pathogens so let's look at how
macrophage can kill pathogens
now macrophage can engulf these
pathogens and inside the macrophage
there are oxidative bursts an oxidative
burst is a process by which macrophage
generates
reactive oxygen species and reactive
oxygen species are important mechanism
by which
macrophages can eliminate pathogens
dendritic cells also plays several
important roles
one role is they secrete inflammatory
cytokines but they also
have a long term role to play they
interact with
t cells and activate t cells and that
brings out the
long-term effect of inflammation so
in this video we have reviewed several
aspects of acute inflammations like what
are the
mediators of acute inflammation we
talked about cellular and molecular
mediators
we talked about the hallmarks of acute
inflammation and lastly we looked at the
molecular and cellular changes
which are associated with acute
inflammation
so i hope this video was comprehensive
and informative if you like this video
give it a quick thumbs up
don't forget to check out all of my
playlist it would be really helpful for
your preparation
and as usual don't forget to like share
and subscribe you can follow me on
instagram or facebook my id is given
here
do let me know in the comments how you
like my videos and if you have any
suggestion please post it in the
comments thank you